so far we've been seeing that we can use
our game diagrams more or less
exclusively we've been representing like
single complex numbers or individual
compacts payments I should say how we
representing them as points or as
vectors right but the important thing is
there are individual complex numbers in
fact he is egg one look there it is
right and he said - he said one pasta -
there they are all kind of isolated from
each other okay now this is analogous to
in the Cartesian plane from the complex
plane if I give you sets of coordinates
you can say he's three one you know
negative one negative or you can pop the
orbit okay but instead of if providing
you individual numbers I say give you a
relationship between before it passes
that instead again individual points for
vectors you get curves or regions for
instance just think in terms of the
Cartesian plane if you have to think
about not just some actual coordinate
but if I say okay y equals x squared now
we all know what y equals x squared
looks like but what does that mean right
what it means is I'm not not looking at
am a bunch of individual points but I'm
looking at that set of points all of the
points such that if you look at Y its
value is the x value squared okay it's a
set of points it's a collection it's a
curve I could ask for region as well I
could say well can you um can you tell
me where the set of points is where X is
greater than zero and you would say well
here's X is equal to zero I'm not
including the boundary but everything
else to the right hand side all of those
points every single one of them
satisfies that inequality right so I've
got a region or I've got a curve which
represents a set of all these points all
vectors okay so we can do in the
Cartesian way there's no
why we can't do it in the complex plane
all right
but just remembering that when you think
about points and vectors we stop
thinking about these just as like we
America we start thinking about them
geometrically so therefore we're going
to get things that represent geometry
basically right now well we thought
about geometry and graphing we had a
whole new set of ideas based around that
and we called it Lucas right so doing
grass in the complex plane drawing
curves and regions on an Argand diagram
or determining the locus of complex
numbers that fit the certain geometric
pattern or rule those are just three
different ways of saying the same thing
all the same idea okay so let's have a
look at some really simple examples
first we'll begin right down the bottom
of the lab I can't so here just like
here right I'm not just giving you one
complex number I'm asking for all of the
complex numbers that have a this
property okay does that make sense
okay now we can think about this in a
variety of ways we can think about this
algebraically we can think about it
geometrically I'm going to do both okay
the absolute value the modulus Ozen what
is that like you've said is X plus iy
how do I calculate the modulus okay I'll
give you x squared plus y square taking
those coefficients of the real imaginary
parts right so I've got this like so
okay now if I want to graph this thing
well I guess I should probably square
things out so it's nice and simple and I
know exactly what this shape is this is
a circle with Center at the origin
radius - okay which of course we ought
to expected because what does this mean
geometrically this means our distance
from the origin I want that whole set of
points whose distance from the origin is
2 which of course is this circle okay so
let's just quickly draw it yeah it's
just a simple one to begin
okay okay yeah all right now just think
about it right what this means I'm gonna
come back over here what this means is
that I can pick any point on say this
blue parabola right point likes it yeah
I can take its Y value and I can take
its x value and they will satisfy this
equation right over here I should be
able to take any of these coordinates
like let's put said there look what did
here or anywhere else you mike and you
take the modulus to that point you'll
get su-9 does that make sense so that's
that's what we mean that's that's not
complicated that's like well this is
pretty this is pretty young pretty calm
let's have a look at another kind of
example let's say let's do this okay
what does this mean well this is a
little tricky to think about exclusively
geometrically rather than not that
Matata let's think about the algebra
first and then see what that tells us
about the geometry okay the Zed is a
complex number by definition that means
it's got a real and an imaginary part
said Baja is the conjugate which means
in this particular comics number it's
going to be X - good now we've noticed
like the important thing about
conjugates is that when you do lots of
operations on them or you get left with
it is the real component right so you
can see my two imaginary parts you're
gonna cancel that gives me this and then
all I need to do is divide through okay
so I know how to graph this in fact I
almost did just over here I just need to
shift it a little bit less strong
it's not increases above the boundaries
so I'm going to put a dive right in and
then everything over here at every
complex number over here has a real
component that's bigger than two that's
simple right by the way you can notice I
could have just as easily said could
just as easily have stated that as the
real component of Z being red than two
but do you see how those are the same
thing there's just different notations
I wouldn't think of any reason why you
wouldn't because it does it does go on
forever in some ways you find if I had
not being that there's no like fill the
hollow circles that also kind of implies
that it's going forever because I've
never said it stops but being that I
mean and it's gonna go on forever I
don't see any reason not to notice are
you tricking me you know that's where
that's where we start to get out of like
how many different ways can I draw a
line to indicate it's alive but it's not
alive it's on there yeah I think that's
fairly unambiguous yes that's a great
question I'm going to in a real what's
gonna say in a real sense that makes it
that makes it I'm I'm not going to I'm
not going to because I'm strictly Spain
this is the complex plane right if I
just say if I just label this x and y
there's nothing that you indicate at the
moment but there's any imaginary
component to this right for all I know
this is a real number and this is also a
real number
hence the Cartesian plane not the
complex plane right so even though this
is talking about Y values it's not just
talking about why those I'm specifying
by way of the
on the axes that these Y values are not
real they are imaginary okay so to say
real Zed here indicates like their
values not the actual axis itself does
that make sense
so I'm still gonna call them really okay
yeah you mean here like there yeah get
to where you need to include open
circles and where you don't need to I
don't think there's anything I don't
think that takes away from the answer
but I don't think it has anything either
like the dotted line already indicates
I'm excluding that boundary and I can't
do it okay there will be points later on
then we'll look at it across this lesson
where you do actually have to specify
that but you generally have to specify
it where you've included the boundary
except for a particular spot where is he
my dotted line already excludes the
boundary because it's a dotted line okay
now just really quickly before we leave
this diagram let's just be a bit cheap
if my asks you for it says now that you
know this that these are equivalent if I
just said okay now graph for me this
where would that be what would that look
like
that's imaginary right so that's my
up-down
okay and you'd put in one and then you'd
say notice I've included my boundary
don't you say everything I don't need
and so this is not a complicated idea I
almost said it wasn't a complex idea
this is a complex idea just not a
complicated okay